>> Tucker: TIME NOW FOR
FINAL EXAM WHERE WE PIT TWO
NEWS PROFESSIONALS HERE AT
FOX AGAINST ONE ANOTHER TO
DETERMINE WHO HAS BEEN
PAYING CLOSER ATTENTION TO
THE NEWS OF THE PAST WEEK.
OUR THREE-TIME DEFENDING
CHAMPION HERE FOR A FOURTH
WEEK CARLEY SHIMKUS, FOX
NEWS HEADLINE 24/7 REPORTER
AND CONTRIBUTOR TO "FOX &
FRIENDS."
HER CHALLENGER THIS WEEK,
FOX CHIEF NATIONAL
CORRESPONDENT ED HENRY.
>> BIG TITLE.
>> Tucker: ON THIS SHOW LAST
NIGHT IN A VERY DIFFERENT
TITLE CAR CAR HE IS A
HEAVYWEIGHT.
>> LITERALLY.
>> Tucker: NO ONE HAS BEEN
ABLE TO STOP CARLEY SO FAR.
PUT YOUR HANDS ON THE
BUZZER.
I ASK THE QUESTIONS.
FIRST ONE TO BUZZ IN GETS TO
ANSWER.
WAIT UNTIL I FINISH THE
QUESTION TO DO THAT.  EVERY
CORRECT ANSWER IS WORTH A
POINT.
GET IT WRONG WE SUBTRACT A
BEST OF FIVE WINS.
READY?
>> I THINK WE CAN HANDLE
THAT.
>> GOOD LUCK.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: A 13-YEAR-OLD
WENT VIRAL DURING JUSTIN
TIMBERLAKE’S HALFTIME SHOW
DURING THE SUPER BOWL
BECAUSE HE SEEMED VERY
DISTRACTED.
WHAT WAS HE DOING?
ED HENRY?
>> HE WAS ON HIS PHONE.
HE TOOK A SELFIE WITH JUSTIN
TIMBERLAKE BUT THERE WAS
SOMETHING, HE WAS WATCHING A
VIDEO AND IT BROKE DOWN OR
SOMETHING SO HE GOT TEASED.
>> Tucker: THAT’S A LONG
ANSWER.
>> HE WAS ON ELLEN.
I SAW HIM ON ELLEN.
>> Tucker: WE WILL ROLL THE
TAPE AND FIND OUT.
>> MEALS OF 13-YEAR-OLD RYAN
MCKENNA STEALING THE
SPOTLIGHT POKING FUN AT THE
TEENAGER FOR STARING AT HIS
PHONE TOO MUCH WHILE THE POP
STAR WAS RIGHT NEXT TO HIM.
>> THE KID SHOULD HAVE TAKEN
A SELFIE WITH JUSTIN BEHIND
HIM AND PUT THE PHONE DOWN
AND ENJOYED THE SHOW.
JUST LIKE WE ALL DO EVERYONE
HAS TO HAVE THEIR PHONE AND
TAPE EVERYTHING.
>> Tucker: THAT’S A VERY
UNCLEAR ANSWER.
>> NO.
I DISPUTE THAT.
>> Tucker: ARE JUDGES ARE
SAYING HE GOT IT.
>> HE WAS ON HIS PHONE.
HE SAID ON ELLEN OR GOOD
MORNING AMERICA THAT HE WAS
WATCHING A VIDEO AND SAID HE
GOT TEASED BECAUSE THE PHONE
BROKE DOWN.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE WATCHING
BOTH ELLEN AND GOOD MORNING
AMERICA?
>> YES.
>> Tucker: LET’S TALK LATER.
QUESTION TWO, A WORLD LEADER
MADE NEWS THIS WEEK WHEN HE
CHASTISED A WOMAN FOR USING
THE PHRASE MANKIND WHICH IS
A SEXIST PHRASE IN HIS
COUNTRY.
THIS LEADER RECOMMENDS MORE
INCLUSIVE TERMS LIKE PEOPLE
KIND.
WHO WAS IT?
>> WAIT, SHE DID IT -- HE
HADN’T FINISHED.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> Tucker: JUDGES?
>> HE FINISHED SAYS THE
JUDGES.
>> THAT WOULD BE CANADIAN
PRIME MINISTER JUSTIN
TRUDEAU.
>> Tucker: NOT JUSTIN
TIMBERLAKE TRUFN TRUDEAU.
>> THE OTHER J.T.
>> Tucker: HERE WE GO.
PRIME MINISTER JUSTIN
TRUDEAU IS REALLY SERIOUS
ABOUT MAKING CANADIANS WATCH
THEIR LANGUAGE.
MATERNAL LOVE
IS THE LOVE THAT’S GOING TO
CHANGE THE FUTURE OF
MANKIND.
>> WE LIKE TO SAY PEOPLE
KIND NOT NECESSARILY
MANKIND.
THAT’S MORE INCLUSIVE.
>> YES.
>> VERY INCLUSIVE.
IS HE A INCLUSIVE GUY.
>> Tucker: LET ME JUST SAY
THAT OUR JUDGES, I’M NOT
SURE WHY THEY MAKE THE
DECISIONS THEY DO.
BUT YOU DON’T ASK THOSE KIND
OF QUESTIONS.
THESE IS VERY HIERARCHAL
SHOW THE JUDGES ARE IN
CHARGE.
>> CERTAIN NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES.
>> Tucker: NO, I DON’T.
I NEVER CHALLENGE.
QUESTION THREE, WHICH
77-YEAR-OLD LAWMAKER JUST
SET A RECORD FOR THE LONGEST
CONTINUOUS SPEECH NUT
HISTORY OF THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES CAUSING SOME
OF HER COLLEAGUES TO DOZEN
OFF IN THEIR CHAIRS?
CARLEY SHIMKUS?
>> THAT WOULD BE NANCY
PELOSI.
>> Tucker: NANCY PELOSI.
I DON’T THINK SHE IS 77 BUT
WE’LL FIND OUT.
CHECK THE TAPE.
>> AND NANCY PELOSI, OH, SHE
PUNISHES I MEAN PROMOTES THE
DREAMERS WITH A MARATHON
8-HOUR SPEECH.
GOOD FOR HER.
4-INCH HEELS, TOO.
COME EARLY.
>> EVEN DEMOCRATS AREN’T
HAPPY WITH THE MINORITY
LEADER’S PERFORMANCE.
ONE OF NANCY’S COLLEAGUES
FELL ASLEEP DURING THE
SPEECH.
>> THAT’S UNDERSTANDABLE,
RIGHT?
>> Tucker: OUR JUDGES
CONCEDE THE SORT OF BACK END
OF THIS, CAN YOU SEE THE
METRICS SAY THAT YOU BUZZED
IN JUST MILLISECONDS BEFORE
YOUR COMPETITOR.
>> SO IT DOESN’T COUNT.
>> Tucker: IT DOES
COUNSELED.
RULES?
>> NO I WAS COMPLIMENTING.
>> REACTION.
>> BEND THE RULES.
>> Tucker: SHE IS FAST.
QUESTION FOUR, TWO TO ONE.
BILLIONAIRE ELON MUSK JUST
LAUNCHED A TESLA ROADSTER
INTO SPACE WITH MAN CAN IN
THE DRIVER’S SEAT BECAUSE HE
CAN DO WHATEVER HE WANTS.
HEADED FOR THE TRACK BUT
WHAT WAS ITS ORIGINAL
DESTINATION?
ED HENRY?
>> MARS, THE ORBIT AND MARS.
>> Tucker: MARS, THE ORBIT
AROUND MARS.
ALL RIGHT.
LET’S CHECK THE TAPE.
>> AND JUST FOR FUN.
THE PAY LOAD ON THE TEST
FLIGHT WAS A BRAND NEW
ELECTRIC TESLA ROADSTER
WHICH IS NOW HEADING TO THE
MARS ORBIT.
STAR MAN ASTRONAUT DUMMY IN
THE DRIVER’S SEAT THREE
CAMERAS TO PROVIDE EPIC
VIEWS.
>> Tucker: THAT IS CORRECT.
BY THE WAY OUR JUDGES SAID
THEY ADMIRED THE PRECISION
IN WHICH YOU ANSWERED IT.
THE MARS OR THE ORBIT
AROUND.
>> CASTING A WIDE NET.
>> Tucker: THIRD WEEK IN A
ROW CARLEY HAS COME TO
SUDDEN DEATH.
TWO TO TWO.
WINNER OF THIS TAKES THE
AWARD.
>> Tucker: FINAL QUESTION.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF TECH
CHANGING EVERYTHING.
BEST BUY, THE COMPANY,
ANNOUNCED THIS WEEK THAT
THEY WOULD NO LONGER BE
SELLING WHICH MUSIC RELATED
PRODUCT?
>> OH.
ED HENRY.
>> CDS.
>> Tucker: THAT’S PRETTY
AUTHORITATIVE.
>> IT’S NOT 8 TRACKS.
>> Tucker: CDS.
>> ARRESTED COG TO REPORT IN
BILLBOARD BEST BUY HAS JUST
TOLD MUSIC SUPPLIERS HAD
WILL PULL CDS FROM ITS
STORES COME JULY 1ST.
THERE YOU GO.
CARLEY SHIMKUS.
>> LET HIM HAVE IT.
SUCH A NICE.
>> Tucker: IF YOU ARE GOING
TO LOSE TO SOMEONE IT SHOULD
BE A NICE GUY.
>> Tucker: NEW ERA.
ERIC WIMPLE OF "THE
WASHINGTON POST" GUEST ON
THE SHOW AT ONE POINT.
HERE IS WHAT HAPPENED TO HIM
AND THE BACK SIDE IS MY
TRIUMPHANT FACE.
VERY FIRST DAY OF
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I WILL DRINK THIS WITH
HONOR.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU BOTH.
THAT WAS GREAT.
>> HAD FUN.
>> Tucker: PAY ATTENTION ALL
WEEK.
FINAL EXAM IS OVER NOW BUT